une réunion pour préparer l'avenir des
républicains objectif de cette rencontre
débat organisée ce mardi 10 avril à
trappes
après une année 2010 est marquée par la
défaite de françois fillon dernière
présidentielle
on a une vraie crise qui est une crise
d'abord de compréhension qu'est ce qui
est arrivé qu est ce qui nous est à vie
pour reconstruire un grand parti de
droite
un débat qui s'est tenu sur fond de
divisions internes pierre bédier en
course pour le poste de président la
fédération l ère des yvelines a vu sa
candidature contestée dans une tribune
par près de 150 élus locaux dans ce
contexte alexandra dublanche élus de
sartrouville a annoncé sa candidature
moi je ne prends pas ça comme une
opposition à pierre bédier - je pense et
je le regrette un que cette pensée il ne
la partage pas qui vaut mieux faire une
équipe parce que le débat qu'on va
ouvrir il faut faire attention voilà je
pense que nos militants sont encore
convalescents nos jeunes amis eux
pensent qu'il faut affirmer une autre
idée bon c'est ses droits c'est le
principe de la démocratie
la soixantaine de militants présents
dans la salle est divisée sur le sujet
est-ce qu y at-il vraiment une division
mois pour moi y'a
divergence de point de vue ça reste une
élection interne faut que ça se fasse
dans la dans une dans une certaine
sérénité et de surcroît faut bien se
rappeler que à la fin il faudra qu'on se
réunisse tous derrière un seul et même
président les élections qui doivent se
dérouler en interne en octobre prochain
seront sans doute animée